I think you've talked before about this
industry wants to be able to work with
people that are easy to work with so
someone's receiving notes what are some
tips that they're resistant whether it's
in their body language whether it's
keywords are using and vice versa
showing that they're open you always
want to really listen during an out
session it's not your time to defend the
work it's your time to listen to take
the physical notes to jot down thoughts
don't defend the work you know I've had
occasions where writers were given and
out and an executive called out
something it was a problem and the
writers women it's not problem I don't
think it's a problem do you think it's a
problem I don't think it's a problem
it's not a problem that sort of thing is
an obvious giveaway that the writer is
not listening it's listening to the
notes it's listening to the note behind
the note if there is something that
truly truly truly you think the
executive the person giving you notes
didn't get you can say well I tried to
illustrate that with this in this
particular scene was that not clear you
want to always ask those leading
questions to find out where you missed
the mark because ultimately the mark was
missed can we assume that once in a
while an executive will miss something
yeah and usually they're pretty open to
oh I didn't realize that this connects
that maybe we can do that better it's
usually very easy to tell when a writer
is resistant to notes when the writer is
instantly defensive when the writer
becomes sarcastic or passive-aggressive
and there's a lot of passive aggression
that can come out in a note session
they're like well I thought or not fine
so you know I've seen it in note
sessions with my writers and I've and
I've given some brutal notes and there
have been people who just sat down and
jotted notes and said okay let me go
back and think about it and there are
people who with every note would say
well I don't know that I necessarily
agree with that but fine so you have
those little cues that you know you know
in a minute body language first
dismissal there can be a judgement of
the individual giving notes well you
your
so naturally you would think that I've
certainly gotten that that feedback or
anything that has to do with you you're
a woman you're a mother I've gotten that
well you're you're a mother so clearly
you couldn't relate to that no I'm a
human being try for Ryder taking notes
try not to dismiss the note giver
because ultimately all that does is
sabotage the relationship because what
you're saying is yes you took the time
you did the work you read the script and
now you're giving me your thoughts but
I'm gonna dismiss them because suddenly
something about you makes you not good
enough to give those notes you're a
mother you're a woman you're white
you're black you're whatever you are but
it's really important not to dismiss the
note giver especially not in front of
the note giver so that there can be a
dialogue oftentimes a writer can receive
a note and be perplexed by the note but
the thing then is to look for the note
behind the note okay you gave me a note
about X but does it really have to do
with Y is this what's bothering you and
you can certainly explore that in a
conversation you want there to be a
dialog and you want to build a kind of
trust where the note giver knows that
you're listening you're paying attention
you're taking those notes so that when
you say you know there's one thing here
that's bumping me can we talk about that
a little bit
that's not defensive that's thoughtful
saying there's the one thing I agree
with your list of 20 other notes totally
here you were good but there's the one
thing here and it's bumping me can we go
back to that for a minute what was it
about this character the scene this
pivot this escalation that bumped you
what what was that it felt inauthentic
was that could it be something else that
to me is dialogue and it's
differentiating between shutting down
the note giver which can be done
physically just you know I'm no longer
interested it can be done verbally or
getting into a more collaborative
environment which is what executives
want to work with they don't want the
writer to be a yes person there's a
difference between being a yes person
and being collaborative being
collaborative will require some pushback
on occasion and that's okay but you
better be really thoughtful about your
pushback
you know that is somebody that people
want to work with I didn't you suggested
X I didn't do X because ultimately I
thought would affect the script this way
but the no behind the note implied that
Y would work so I tried that this time
that's being collaborative that's not
being a yes person and the truth of the
matter is that a lot of writers think
that they're given notes and the
executive just wants them to implement
the note verbatim I find that to be very
rarely the case if that was it the
executive would be a writer you know
they're giving they're throwing out
ideas they're trying different things
and you they want you to try them on for
size and see whether they work or they
not they don't work so if there's a note
that they gave on a previous draft that
you didn't implement they want you to be
able to answer why you didn't implement
they want you to be able to say well I
tried that and the way that it affected
the script was this and because of that
I realized it didn't work and I took it
out but I did something else to offset
your note wouldn't they want a yes
person no why because they want the
writer to bring their creative juices to
it that's why they hire a writer with a
specific story Sensibility with a
particular skill set with a particular
taste level for a particular project
right they want somebody who will bring
their unique sensibilities to the
project otherwise hire a typist get the
script hire a typist and have the type
of type in whatever needs to be typed in
they want in of course there are the few
executives that are known around town
for being really locked into their notes
and they want their notes implemented
the way they want them implemented and
that's it and it's not a conversation
but by and large I find that the
creative execs executive producers
producers development execs are all
looking for a creative partner as
opposed to just somebody to execute on
the page they can get their assistant to
execute on the page they don't need you
for that there would be much better off
giving the material to their assistant
who has a bachelor's in English Lit to
implement some changes than going back
and forth with you they don't
want you to be a yes person they want
you to provide your unique story
sensibilities your unique writerly touch
to make their notes that can be quite
shitty come off sing singing off the
page
you